Okay guys, we're going to make a start. Thanks everyone for joining today's webinar. As just
a quick bit of housekeeping, the webinar will be recorded and uploaded to our YouTube channel
the next couple of days, just due to the volume of attendees as well. We're not going to be doing
a live Q&A at the end of the session like we have in the past, but you will be receiving an email
to make sure that you've got an opportunity to speak to us and even schedule a meeting with
myself or the wider team at PultzWigger to explore API scanning with the enterprise in more detail,
should you like what you see in the webinar. With that being said, let's make a start.
And meet the team. So those of us today at PultzWigger presenting is myself, Alex, and I work in the
enterprise sales team at PultzWigger. I'm Katie. I'm a product manager on
scanning here at PultzWigger. And I'm Josh. I'm here with customer success for our enterprise
customers. Thank you guys. In terms of today's agenda, so obviously the focus is going to be on
API scanning and some new features that we've launched recently for Berkswee Enterprise. We're
going to discuss around the need for an API scanning in the first place, what that actually looks like in
Berkswee Enterprise Edition. Josh is going to take us through a bit of a demo in terms of what a scan
might look like at the configuration options available. For those interested, after having said
all that, we'll look at what the next steps look like as well. So to begin with, why do we need
purpose-built API scanning functionality? So I'm sure this audience has their own thoughts on kind of
current challenges around APIs. And by the way, we would love to hear those challenges in order,
Rob's to help you as well. But generally speaking, as an industry trend, there is certainly a growing
reliance on APIs and microservices in model web apps and probably a lot of legacy estates still out
there as well. And data for EDS Global suggests that organisations across many different industries
are reporting an average of 26 APIs per web application. And this number is really only
growing over time. And we certainly speak to customers with hundreds or even thousands of endpoints
that they have to manage across the board. And in combination with that, less than 50% of
application security professionals actually have dedicated API testing tools in place. So it's a bit of
a combination of two problems there, having that visibility across the web application portfolio
with that increasing number of APIs, and actually having effective tools that are specifically designed
to test them. And for those customers who haven't addressed those issues yet, we're only really
increasing the risks. One thing to highlight in terms of Port Swigger and our tool sets is that API
scanning in of itself is not necessarily a new feature. It is something that we've offered
in the past with the BirdScanner. So we started with REST API support to which we added GraphQL as well,
in the context of a web application scan. But the feedback we were getting from our customer base
was that we wanted a specific focus on API scanning versus that end web app scan, which is what we've
been working quite hard behind the scenes to deliver on. For those on the call that are BirdScreen
professional users, it's perhaps important to call out that enterprise is based on the same scanning
technology as professional, which of course you already know who else.
I'll just spend a couple of minutes giving an example of an actual customer use case,
a customer that I've spoken to recently that kind of focused on API scanning. I've just tried to pick out
some of the themes that would hopefully resonate with you. So we were talking to a fairly large
organisation that did have a dedicated AppSec team. Their focus in terms of testing was split between
the QA environment, but also their production or externally facing applications. And they had a bit
of a mixture of both internal and external definitions or collections of APIs. As we just alluded to
in the previous slide, those numbers are growing. And with that context being set,
the challenges that they were seeing was, of course, the overarching one that we want to protect
the data and the web applications that we look at today. There was a bit of a theme of lacking visibility
of all the endpoints, all the definitions that are out there across lots of different teams and verticals,
etc. And they were moving towards this notion that they wanted to test APIs before changes were
hitting production, not just testing the externally facing web applications and still as fact.
So when we discussed the kind of impact that any of these challenges might have,
of course, kind of worst case scenario would be something along the lines of a data breach,
which would be quite detrimental to the business itself. Just not knowing how vulnerable they are
and how to kind of prioritise their activities was a bit of a headache. And then resources around scaling their
processes. But this was more specifically in that notion of bringing API testing into the QA or
or staging process where the resources were now really revolving around the companies.
So when we spoke to the customer around BIRT Suite Enterprise, these were the kind of two
areas of focus in terms of how we would be successful. So primarily that was around that visibility
component of vulnerable API definitions. And having that like a known entity, which
which Katie is going to take us through in a moment. And then BIRT Suite Enterprise as a product does
integrate with the pipeline. It's one of the main use cases that we discuss with our customers. So we
can absolutely support that notion of integrating DAST and API testing into QA, staging pre-prod before we
talk about release and things to production.
So with all that being said, we're going to get into the meat of things and talk about how we've gone
about introducing enhanced API scanning in BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition. And for this, we've changed it.
Thank you. So as Alex said before, we have had API scanning in BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition for a long
time now. And so I'm going to cover what we've brought into the tool in our enhancements. As we
understand that users want to be able to scan API definitions in isolation. So we're hoping that this
will expand our capabilities even further. So I'll cover the following four in our new additional
features. The first will be uploading API definition files directly into BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition,
identifying vulnerable APIs with our new OpenAPI scan check, how to test OpenAPI schemas with
different endpoints, and also looking into our authentication offerings as well.
First up, just a common thing that we hear from our customers is they often have access to their
OpenAPI files, but can't scan them in isolation without running a full web app scan. So this feature
now allows you to directly upload API definitions straight into BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition. And this can be
done in two ways. The first is by adding in a URL, which you can see there on the left. This allows
you to put the URL in and scan the latest version of your API definition. The second offering is by
directly uploading the file into the tool. This is a more static file and will need to be updated each
time a definition file changes. We currently support schemas for OpenAPI on version 2 and version 3.0 as well.
API testing, as Alex said, is becoming more important as vulnerabilities and APIs are becoming more common.
So we now include active and passive scan checks for detecting OpenAPI definition-storied scams.
The scan check uses a list of common OpenAPI definition file names and locations to search for
publicly available definitions. This will then flag them in your enterprise and pose them as potential
security threats. Next up is we understand that a lot of API definition files have a lot of endpoints
and being able to filter through them and see what's actually going to be covered is really important.
What we are able to offer now is that you'll be able to see all of the endpoints that you can find and
parse that file and also filter really quickly through them. This should allow you to quickly start any
destructive actions out of scope so you can get the best coverage and therefore get more comprehensive
scans, giving you a high number of vulnerabilities identified.
Finally, API scanning more often than not requires authentication. You can do this seamlessly now
as you set up your scan. We currently support basic authentication, bearer tokens and API keys,
and there will be more to come soon. For static files, this will be auto detected while you upload. You can
then add edit, add new, change, whatever you need to do to update your authentication. For a URL scan,
you will be setting this up as part of your configuration and it will be passed through for your scan.
Thanks, Katie. Okay, guys, now we're going to go into the demo portion and take a look at some of those
specific features that we've just run through, just to add some kind of additional context before Josh
makes a start. So now when we onboard an application to Enterprise, you have a choice. Now you can either
scan essentially a front-end web application, so typically we're passing a URL for the scanner to
target. Now in the context of APIs, any direct data paths between that front-end and API endpoints would
still be covered within the context of that scan. So that'll be kind of option number one for you. If you
want to test APIs specifically, as we'll see from Josh, we now have that option available where you can
pick an API scan and then how you want to provide that definition. And so Josh, over to you. Take it away.
Thanks, Alex. So I'm just going to swipe over here seamlessly and what we can see straight away is Burbs
Console. Now if we go to our site's view as normal, I'm going to go and create a new site. And what you can see here,
as Alex was saying, is I can now choose between a web app and an API. Now with a web app, I can still
scan as I used to, but I can still use my start URLs. And if we discover a solid definition file
during that scan, we'll still scan it as normal as Katie was describing. If I now go to my API site
and then give it a name, I'll just call it SwigginR. I can now choose whether or not to upload a file
of that first URL. Now, as it was mentioned before, if I upload that file, we'll use that same version
every time that I've been to scan. But if I use the host URL, every scan will go to that URL,
always put on the latest version. So if you go to host URL here, put in for example, my size.com
slash API.json. And then under authentication, I can add my credentials. So either basic, bearer,
or API key. I can choose a label, put my username in, and then put my password into. But if I have a
URL, if I have a file I want to upload, I can then upload that directly into the product.
And you can see here under authentication, I've got this red dot, which means that my
authentication method has been passed. And from here, you can see that bearer token has been picked
up from the configuration file. I can then just go in here and add the token in that. And as you
noticed from before, my authentication method, I added his stuff assisted. And if I go to API
credentials, I can also add extra credentials in as I could before. If I now go down to endpoints,
what you can see is that the endpoints from that file have been passed, and I can filter
by HTTP method. I can search for endpoints. I can also change how many endpoints are shown on
this screen. And then I can also filter out particular endpoints that I don't want to scan
during this scan. Under scan settings, I can enter everything that I could set normally for a normal
web app scan. And I'm just going to save this site now. And you can see that this performs exactly
the same way as a normal site in enterprise. When the scan has straight away, you can see
that the scan, that the API is being scanned. Now, as I can with a normal web app, I can also
scan this site using a CI driven scan. So if I swipe over here, what you can see here is some basic
scan configuration that I've got configured. Besides for start URLs, this is how you'd normally do a web
app scan. If I comment this section out, you can see under API definition, I can provide the URL to the
API definition file, or it can also point to the API definition file that I've got hosted locally.
And then the rest of this configuration file is I do normally expect. So that's effectively how you can
run a new scan in enterprise through both the console and the CI driven scan capabilities
of the new API functionality that we've got in enterprise. Here with you.
Thanks, Josh. And so guys, now we're going to talk about the fact that this isn't kind of the end of
our journey when it comes to APIs. We do have some more features planned. I can tell you a quick
tour of those for us now. Yeah. So as I said, this is in the end, we really want to continuously
improve API offerings. So we mentioned earlier that we already support REST APIs and RQL for our scanning.
And very soon in the next month or so, SOAP APIs will also be supported. We are constantly evaluating
and wanting to bring even more schemes in. So this should continue to grow. We also want to increase
our authentication support. So as I said before, basic barotaging and API accordingly, but we know
there are plenty more that people are interested in. So this is something that we are continually looking at
and incorporating into the tool. The last, but finally, not by not means least, we're aware that a lot of
people want to be able to upload that API definition whilst they're doing a web app scan. So bring the
two in together. So this is something that we are looking to build into the tool over the next few months.
And hopefully you'll be able to do both very soon within Enterprise Edition.
Thanks Katie. So that's going to be it from us folks in terms of our API date. For next steps,
everybody who registered, you are going to receive an email and you'll be invited to request a trial of
Bits for Enterprise Edition. So if you'd like to explore the product in more detail, maybe take a look
specifically at the API features and functions that we've mentioned here, and we would certainly encourage you
to do so. That process will enable you to speak to one of our experts who can go and support you
through a deeper evaluation. And of course, we'll be happy to answer any questions that have been
generated from this session. As I already said, the recording of this session will also be made
available. In terms of our actual process over here at Wolfsweger, once you get that email, you can submit
just a few details to us. That will then result in a call with either myself or my colleagues in the
Enterprise team. We'll discuss your requirements, what you might be doing today versus what you want
to achieve in the future. That would typically then lead on to a product demo, maybe delivered by Josh
itself. So again, we'll go a bit more deeper into the product. We can cover other areas,
other integrations that we support. Again, if you're only interested in the API feature,
we can deep dive on that. And if that's ticking all the boxes for you, we would then support full
trial or evaluation. So that's all said and done. Guys, before you go, there will be another short
poll appearing on the screen, if you'd be so kind as to complete that. But we really appreciate you
joining. Many thanks from the team here at Wolfsweger. But yeah, that's all from us folks.
Thanks guys. You take care.
Thanks.